qu'ils valent rock en seine attendait
une explosion ils ont eu droit à une
implosion
juste avant de rentrer sur scène les
frères gallagher fondateur du groupe
mythique oasis se sont bagarrés en loge
résultat ils ont tiré un trait sur le
concert sur la tournée européenne et sur
le groupe lui-même
christophe airaud entonna broutards
thierry breton 22 heures hier soir
déclarations des organisateurs de rock
en seine se sont battus ils étaient
venus pour oasis oasis n'est pas là
alors ils repartent annulations de
dernière minute et colère des
spectateurs ça fait mal c'est vrai que
sur le coup ça fait mal je suis très
déçu moi j'étais à l'onu une dernière
amy winehouse ou pas vous je suis là
cette année un concert annulé pour cause
de bagarre et de bagarre entre deux
frères car oasis c'est noël et liam
gallagher
ils se détestent depuis toujours et hier
après midi dans les loges
on dispute une guitare brisé les portes
claquent noël quitte le festival pour
l'organisation c'est un coup dur mais
est rock'n'roll c'est bien mais un
moment faut aussi avoir un minimum de
responsabilité que ce soit à leurs
vis-à-vis des organisateurs de
spectacles qui vous feront confiance et
chivu programme
c'est une chose mais surtout surtout
vis-à-vis du public mais je dépasse
leurs hôtes vaches aux as this et la pop
anglaise des années 90 des superstars
des dizaines de millions d'albums vendus
il joue à merveille les mauvais garçons
je suis qu'un sale bâtard n'en avais tu
sympa mais je suis aussi un mauvais
garçon mais cet ultime combat
signe peut être la fin du groupe
dans la nuit c'est madness qui a pris la
relève mais pour rock en seine c'est une
malédiction en 2007 2008 amy winehouse
elle aussi annuler au dernier moment les
caprices de rockers vont finir par
écorné l'image du festival
quelques belles